6 26 into wednesday morning got a
tribute now to nevada department of
transportation spokesman tony ilya who
passed away unexpectedly the other day
what's driving you crazy viewers you've
heard tony's name
hundreds of times down through the years
from helping me help you
navigate the billion dollar headaches of
project neon to sending photos of
overnight
concrete pours or emergency mud and
debris clearing of a highway
up in lincoln county tony was never
farther away than a text message
whatever else he had going on tony was
always more than helpful
ended every communication with me with
the word cheers
so cheers to your memory tony if you
ever find yourself grumpy about a
project project-related traffic
nightmare
please remember not only tony but all
the hard-working men and women toiling
away on the road to better
transportation for all of us
and as much as he will be missed tony's
co-worker
adrian packer is more than capable of
carrying on his hard work and dedication
to keeping you informed
about the never-ending road construction
we all face every day
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone
if there is something driving you crazy
email me traffic eight at eight news now
dot com